foreign
spy series mixed with an impossible love
story and lots of action when I first
started working on this you kind of had
to figure out how to ground it how to
make you really believe you were right
inside the action
when I read the script and I started to
look at the scale of what was proposed I
thought oh is this happening on
television we were talking about a flood
and an airplane almost crashing I'm
thinking you're gonna do this stuff
I think the one we can imagine the most
clearly is they hack into the train
system we've lost all control over the
signals and not only did we have to plan
the crash itself
we had to also plan and shoot a huge
aftermath scene
real trains and we cut them up into
pieces and we've made this completely
authentic we have hundreds of extras
here today with Ava Green in the middle
amongst all this chaos you know I was
expecting to shoot that scene against
Green Screen so when I arrived on set I
was like oh my God this amazing the
train had been derailed lots of smoke
everywhere all the extras were like
wounded passengers it was very
impressive
is very intense on screen there's
something very rugged very animal about
him that suits the character of Gabriel
beautifully I'm not a big guy so how do
you do it when the guy is twice your
size and you have to do what you got to
do yeah exactly you go straight to the
point
it's a forward moving Thriller with a
dangerous Love Story it's a challenge
but it's really exciting it's extremely
ambitious
it looks good it's believable it's
amazing
thank you
[Music]